leute ich habe einfach die klasse
schifffahrt meines lebens hinter mir
gerade auf dem rückweg
nordsee urlaub also jeder unten erkennt
wer mitfahren
und ich habe gerade so gestört die
sachen bei pokémon gefangen ist einfach
komplett
ich werde jetzt nach nacherzählen was
das unter anderem war also es ist nicht
wirklich klar
ich hätte euch das ganze vielleicht auch
mein anders erzählen weil ich bin gerade
auf dem chip ist schuld verlauf aber
definitiv muss ja ich erzählen was sie
da abgegangen ist das zu crazy als ich
bin mitten auf dem meer mit nachdem ich
jetzt einmal runter zu sebastian der
schneidet gerade unten auf seinen video
der macht seien
kann ja sein dass unser weg aber ich
glaube
die belegungen niedrige stangen
heute geleitet so lässt
nationalen verkauft wurde
so leute ich bin mittlerweile nicht mehr
auf der fähre sondern ich bin mit meiner
freundin und ich erzähle euch jetzt mal
was da überhaupt abgegangen ist weil das
war wohl trat krass das ding ist von der
insel wo ich war fährt man mit der fähre
zurück zu circa 90 minuten und ich
dachte immer mal okay sie noch ein
bisschen langweilig wenn man auf der
fähre zurück fährt mache ich mir einfach
mal ein rauch an
ich habe jetzt einfach den rauch an
gemacht und hab echt nichts böses
gedacht aber plötzlich ging es los
es war unglaublich übrigens mein freund
hat ein loch politisch sponsoren jetzt
ganz nebenbei noch ein paar pokémon
franken auf jeden fall ging das komplett
ab also wir hatten innerhalb von der von
der halben stunde in der rauch aktiv ist
hatten wir glaube ich das wirklich lügen
25 pokémon ski gefahren sind und es war
nicht irgendwelche pokémon jetzt
komplexe story sondern die heftigsten
pokémon überhaupt und zwar beginnt das
ganze ab diesem muss was hier unten
sehen ist ein screenshot mittlerweile
ein paar verschickt habe aber ab diesem
muss hier beginnt das ganze und das war
wirklich verrückt also ihr seht schon
stars wie cary joji kato abra marco
dieck abschluss schon ganz nett so also
hier richtig richtig heftige bubmann
gefangen so die die ich euch gesagt wenn
ich schon ganz gut aber dann ging es los
dann kam onyx mein erstes onyx überhaupt
ist 20 bp 33 aber das war schon ziemlich
krass so weit war ein bisschen
überrascht hat einfach so nix von mitten
auf dem meer klar ich hatte auch an
aber das war schon ziemlich verrückt und
dann kam ein wohl kicks ziemlich hoch
460 ihr seht schon ihm niederknien ist
einfach respond auf dem meer und jetzt
geht's erst jetzt geht's richtig ab und
zwar 1 0 einschlug
und dieses ist dragan mit 2235
ermöglicht wird nicht was abgeht das
schlug zum beispiel hatte ich zwar aus
einem menschlichen durch auch eier von
mir aus geschlüpft sind
ich habe das gesehen einfach nur dass
sandra doran waren ich kann überhaupt
nicht klar also das war für ihn mitten
zwischen zwei eiern die ausgebeutet sind
und ich dachte schon so ok mist jetzt
kann ich mich drauf klicken weil hätte
ausblutet und diese animation dauert ja
immer ein bisschen
ich habe drauf geklickt mein bestes
pokémon im moment irgendwie 1850 die
fragezeichen bei pokémon erscheinen nur
wenn sie besser sind als
bestes pokémon und das war bei diesem
drama der fall ihr seht schon 2235
ultras und ansonsten hatte ich noch
einen fleck fiction ein flughafen also
es ist wirklich absolut sinnfreie
teilweise was da für den wii sports sind
aber ich war so heißt also dieses trage
ganz einfach so krass ist mit abstand
mein bestes pokémon ich zeig euch das
noch mal in der richtigen app also die
die coolen hofmann unter denen ich hatte
zwei mal rauch angemacht auf die
geschäft ich bin glaube ich mit 80 pro
quellen drauf gegangen und mit zwei
super wellen zurückgekommen weil es so
krass war und insbesondere das drago
anzufangen war so heftig ich habe ja
noch ein paar snaps aus der snapshot
sorry von meinem bruder das natürlich
direkt festgehalten hat und die werde
ich erstmal einblenden heute wir fahren
hier gerade auf der fähre und max wollen
einfach einen draht uran mit nachdem er
drei fall gezeigt dass es mit den
stärksten
aber reicht nicht aus 21 verletzte
überall
und jetzt
kurz
23 als ob junge in rückstand
übrigens liebe 24 bin ich jetzt die
pokemon die ich in der letzten zeit
insbesondere auch auf der insel wo wir
angefangen habe so verrückt ich zeit
auch gleich noch mal kurz den überblick
über meine besten pokémon aber erst mal
halt die dichte auf dem schiff gefangen
habe so also wie gesagt onyx dann halt
das wohl fix habe ich mittlerweile wohl
ohne entwickelt an nido queen
das fand ich auch vollkommen gras also
die miete bis jetzt halt nicht so hoch
also hat mich so ein hoher wp also was
noch wichtig zu sagen ist die
geschwindigkeit mit der man sich das
überlegt habe waren ungefähr 15 km h und
bei rauch ist das ja so wenig sitzen
bleibt stehen die bei dir zu hause auf
der couch oder im bett oder so wird alle
fünf minuten ein pokémon angelockt und
mit diesen 15 km h die wieder gefahren
sind konstant sind einfach wirklich ja
eigentlich jede minute ist ein pokémon
gekommen das war so versucht verrückt
weil ich habe überhaupt nicht damit
gerechnet dass so viel abgeht kann auf
jeden fall die ganze zeit ultra hat vor
allem bei dem tragbaren versuch heftig
weil ich überhaupt nicht klar kam
wie viele wie viele würfe in der story
von meinem bruder drin waren aber ich
habe 15 verbände geworfen und jeden
einzelnen getroffen also ich hab keinen
fall verworfen
das ist aber nicht drin geblieben und
dann habe ich irgendwie mit dem fünften
superball insgesamt 20 weitere hobbys
gefangen
die wir einfach echt einfach nur hype
weil es einfach so cool erste mal hier
ein kleiner überblick über meine besten
pokémon also drago waren natürlich ganz
oben
cani ist auch noch ganz weiten mit dabei
1828 agrana habe ich mir entwickelt mit
einem 690 eboli dann flamme and one and
only lachse dieser flohmarkt stamme wohl
ohne hypnose auslöser dürften topstar
noch ein pinsel audrey gold in ihre akte
blitzer magnet und so weiter und so fort
wenn ich sehr zufrieden mit meinem
aktuellen team bei pokemon die meisten
konnten seltene pokémon hier habe ich
einfach auch alle auf der insel gefangen
also wisag york da war ich mit luca nach
um drei dass wir zurückgekommen sind vom
feiern haben wir einfach diese wieder
vorgesehen bei mir was ab 1400 war glaub
ich auch 33 oder so und geo was habe ich
auch dort gefangen kühle luft dort
gefangen und inserate in sebastians
video was übrigens heute oder morgen
kommt auch alleine sieben stück gefangen
oder so insgesamt ein sehr sehr pokémon
gleiche pokémon reicher aufenthalt ja
was ihr euch mitnehmen können video was
mit einem kind aus dem video
rowohlt die pokemon gipfel noch nicht
erhalten alle die schnauze danke also
insgesamt wenn irgendwo auf einer fähre
seit oder ich irgendwie so mit 15 km/h
bewegt macht euch einfach an weil es hat
sich noch nie etwas mehr gelohnt bei mir
in pokémon glaub ich habe einfach meine
besten und mit meinem ältesten truppen
und gefangen in dieser eine stunde wo
ich als zweier auch an gemacht habe also
sehr zu empfehlen
ich meine das video hat euch gefallen
falls sie öfter pokémon goal sehen wollt
dann schreibt dass man die kommentare
falls ihr sagt okay der hype ist vorbei
lasst mich in ruhe schreibt das in die
kommentare
und ja ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
macht's gut